بعد اسبوع من انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
التي فشل فيها الجمهوريون في الفوز بعدد
المقاعد التي كانوا يعملونها في الكونجرس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب فاصلين
جديده من المواجهه ضد الرئيس الديمقراطي
جوبايدن تقدم ترامب اوراق ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2024 قبل اعلان
المتوقع من منتجع مرالاغو بانه سيطوب
السباق للبيت الابيض للمره الثانيه ولكن
اللافت ان ترامب تجنب الى حد كبير اعاده
الترويج لمزاعيه من ان انتخابات 2020 قد
سرقت منه بسبب تزوير جماعيا
نحن هنا اليوم لنعلنا انه ليس بالضروره ان
يبقى الوضع على ما هو عليه قبل عامين كنا
امه عظيمه وقريبا سنكون امه عظيمه من جديد
عام 2024 هو الموعد لتصويت افضل هل انتم
مستعدون وانا ايضا مستعد ساضمن عدم حصول
بيض على اربعه اعوام اخرى بلادنا لا
يمكنها ان تتحمل ذلك انني اعلن اليوم
ترشيح نفسي لمنصب رئيس الولايات المتحده
في الجوله المقبله
وينظر الى اعلان ترامب المبكر بشكل غير
عادي لانتخابات الرئاسه لعام 2024 على انه
تكتيك لسرقه الاضواء من المنافسين
المحتملين لترشيح الجمهوريين للبيت الابيض
فعلى الرغم من ان ترامب هو اول من دخل
السباق ثامنه متوقع ان يواجهه منافسين قد
يكون من بين النائبه الرئيسيه السابقه
مايك وحاكم ولايه فلوريدا ارون ديسمبر
وفي اول تعليق على اعلان رئيس الامريكي
السابق دوران ترامب ترشحه للسباق الرئاسيه
المقبل في 2024 اعتبروا الرئيس الحليب
وبعدين في تغريده على تويتر
خذل البلاد خلال توليه المنصب مرفقه
للتغريده ويقول ان ترامب خلال رئاسته تربع
على اقتصاده مزور لصالح الاثرياء وهاجم
النظام الصحي ودلل المتطرفين وهاجم حقوق
المراه وحرض العصابات العنيفه من اجل
محاوله قلب فوزي عام 2020 الى خساره